♪♪
Ambition.
Greed.
♪♪
And a guy named Willy.
Willy Shakespeare.
♪♪
Witch:
By the pricking of my thumbs,
something wicked this way comes.
♪♪
Our version of MacBeth
Mary Zophres:
made Shakespeare accessible.
The way I've always looked at
the film, is that it doesn't
take place in any physical place.
Carter Burwell:
It takes place in the minds of
the characters
Carter Burwell:
and the psychological reality.
Macbeth has been done in many
forms and many time periods.
Mary Zophres:
But we're inspired by Joel's
vision.
Mary Zophres:
Which was this highly defined
black and white
Mary Zophres:
and very geometric and very
architectural.
And that's what helped us come
up with a set of rules on
MacBeth.
What's fascinating is, I don't
know, I think it's the first
time I've worked with
a husband and wife team.
So, that was, that was
interesting.
Just watching the two of them,
how they operate.
Denzel Washington:
They're two halves of the same
person, I mean they rely on each
Denzel Washington:
other and, uh, trust each
other.
They're both brilliant,
brilliant artists and care about
the work.
Ellen Chenoweth:
Joel really wanted the language
to be very specific and very clear.
Ellen Chenoweth:
And he really wanted the actors
and their ability to pull these scenes off.
And make the language sing and
make it real at the same time.
If chance will have me king,
why, chance may crown me without
my stir.
(Sword chopping)
Come what come may.
It's important for Joel, in
films, to usually establish
visual themes,
Carter Burwell:
as well as verbal
themes and auditory themes.
Denzel Washington:
He's just brilliant. He's one of
the most, if not the most,
brilliant filmmaker I've worked
with, period.
There are a lot of things about
working with Joel that are
unique,
compared to working with other
filmmakers.
Joel is known for really
preparing well for pretty much
the whole process.
He had the story and he had the
visuals already in his head.
Seeing how Joel saw it was a
masterclass in, in filmmaking.
(Thunderous knocking)
♪♪
I had done a number of movies
with Joel and Ethan.
Ellen Chenoweth:
So, I had a pretty good sense of
what kinds of actors he liked
Ellen Chenoweth:
and at this point, we had
Frances McDormand.
Ellen Chenoweth:
And once you start thinking
about who can play opposite her,
and hold their own and has had
classical training, it was a
very, very short list.
Ellen Chenoweth:
And then, when Denzel said he
would do it, it was kind of a miracle
because he's classically trained
and he's a huge movie star.
My dearest love...
I mean, he's a giant so that
was, kind of, a dream come true.
...Duncan comes here tonight.
Lady Macbeth:
Look like the innocent flower,
but be the serpent under it.
Leave all the rest to me.
She was amazing.
Amazing.
Denzel Washington:
She's brilliant, really,
and a lovely, lovely woman.
Lovely woman.
(Thunderous knocking)
♪♪
There was no color on set.
There was only a dress or two
that Frances McDormand was
wearing, which were in color.
But otherwise, everything
was black and white.
Bruno Delbonnel:
So, when the actors came on set,
they were really aware of what it looks like.
All was in black and white, all
on sound stages.
Carter Burwell:
We just got these very
exaggerated
Carter Burwell:
abstractions sometimes that come
from the sets.
It was, kind of, obvious it has
to be black and white.
Bruno Delbonnel:
Because black and white already
introduced some, kind of, abstraction, you see.
It's a... you're not
connected to reality, in some
ways, with black and white.
You have already a distance.
Witch:
Double, double, toil and
trouble,
fire burn and cauldron bubble.
(Splash)
First Apparition:
Macbeth, Macbeth...
Macbeth.
With the designs of the sets
being so abstract,
Stefan Dechant:
I never felt the need that
I needed to have any muted color, at all.
And just to move quickly, it was
just easier to paint in grays.
I've done another black and
white movie, and for hair, what
you wanna do, is you're
Cydney Cornell:
not dealing with color.
So, you wanna have shadows and
reflection.
Cydney Cornell:
And then those are your things
you're working with.
Cydney Cornell:
Light or dark, shiny or not
shiny.
Designing a film that's in
black and white
was hugely important.
Mary Zophres:
Texture and textiles and
embroidery and
Mary Zophres:
layering and aging.
All these different tools worked
really well in this form of
black and white.
Will all great Neptune's ocean
wash this blood clean from my
hand?
♪♪
Bruno Delbonnel:
It always came to the way I
would light it.
Bruno Delbonnel:
We never really know if it's day
or night.
Bruno Delbonnel:
and it's really in the play.
So, what if we play with this
idea of not knowing,
Bruno Delbonnel:
or is there a transition that
you can see going from day to night?
It was a fair thing just to be,
kind of, ambiguous with the
light.
Bruno Delbonnel:
The shadows are very sharp.
So, when I use theater light, in
fact, I didn't use any movie light,
it was the light you use for
a rock and roll concert.
Things without all remedy should
be without regard, what's done
is done.
We have scorched the snake, not
killed it.
(Thunderous knocking)
♪♪
Denzel Washington:
The way the film, that Joel
brilliantly made,
Denzel Washington:
that Frances brilliantly played,
it moves.
(Wind blows)
It really moves. You understand
what it is and he took his time
and got it right.
Alex Lemke:
Joel talked to us about how he
wanted to make Macbeth into a film,
Alex Lemke:
while preserving the theatrical
experience of it.
So, he was going to use film
influences, mainly from
German Expressionism, to turn this into a, uh, film.
(Horse neighs)
The format choice that the
movie was shot in,
Michael Huber:
2D backdrops that kind of looked
like backdrops in the real theaters,
and all the artistic choices
that were made, would lead to a
little bit of a, um, abstraction.
Especially in the sequences
where we're not entirely sure
what is reality and what is not,
adds to that level of uh, stage
performance.
Ahh!
So, it's a combination of
backdrops, painted backings,
nets, screens and stuff like that.
Are you a man?
Ay, and a bold one, that dare
look upon that which might
appall the devil.
Bruno Delbonnel:
The academy frame was about the
power of the close-up.
It's a fabulous format.
And, you know, seriously, when
you have Denzel's face, you know
academy fills the frame and,
Bruno Delbonnel:
ah, it's, it's already very
strong
Bruno Delbonnel:
and Frances is the same and has
such a presence.
Being in the academy framing and
being able to be in dialogue and
to draw with Joel.
Stefan Decant:
You could design the sets for
those parameters.
It was designed to leave you not
in a real place.
Carter Burwell:
Gravity isn't quite working
right and you're unsettled by this, as a viewer.
(Screaming)
(Thunderous knocking)
♪♪
Cydney Cornell:
What we're all doing is
contributing to a framed piece of art that Joel is creating.
What we're creating with the
costumes were, sort of, chess
pieces.
All the styles, the costumes and
everything, were just solid
edges.
Mary Zophres:
Shapes, triangular, conical,
cylinder.
And the way people, sort of,
moved around the set were like
chess characters.
Mary Zophres:
I based it on things that would
be flattering first
Mary Zophres:
to Frances McDormand and to
Denzel Washington.
That's one of the reasons why
there's lattice work in the
chest and on the shoulders of the armor.
Mary Zophres:
And there's this tufting
technique that we use on the under-armor.
Mary Zophres:
And a quilting technique that we
used in the sleeves.
Mary Zophres:
And it's all in an effort to
create interest without being distracting in close-ups.
Bruno Delbonnel:
And then it was about shapes.
How can I bring some tension to
the image?
Yes!
(Smashing)
Yet here's a spot. Out, damned
spot! Out, I say!
But it was, uh, trying to find
balance where they have to work
together
Bruno Delbonnel:
the lines and the acting and
the light are in sync.
He, kinda, gives a very clear
idea of what the lighting is
supposed to be on set.
Michael Huber:
And that, kinda, dictates also
what we're gonna be working with later.
So, whatever we do needs to fit
into his lighting scheme.
Stefan Dechant:
It was also Bruno's idea, which
I thought was fantastic,
Stefan Dechant:
oh, let's start painting the
shadows into the sets.
All men else I have avoided
thee, but get thee back, my soul
is too much charged with blood of thine already.
(Thunderous knocking)
♪♪
Frances is brilliant,
obviously, and passionate.
Denzel Washington:
I love her. She's a beast
and so am I.
So, it was a great, uh,
we wouldn't even call it a
battle because it was a concert.
It's just two forces coming
together,
I was getting ready to say for
good,
but not for good, for evil.
But, we did it well.
I don't think it gets better
than working with Bruno as a DP.
Stefan Dechant:
What Bruno brings to it is just
this incredible cinematic history.
Stefan Dechant:
I mean, he's a walking
encyclopedia.
Denzel Washington:
I had a wonderful relationship
with the cinematographer
Denzel Washington:
because he couldn't beat me to
work.
If he was there at five, and I'm
like, "Man, I've been here two
hours."
Denzel Washington:
I would do those speeches and
soliloquies just over and over.
Our collaboration with Bruno was
far closer this time than it
was on, on the last movie
because he was involved a lot
more in the, in the post
process.
Well, it was fun working with
them
and they, they were fabulous.
He would bounce ideas off of us
and ask things that he would
like to try out
Michael Huber:
and see what stuff looks like.
So, it was a, kind of, an
ongoing process. I said "Oh, why
don't we do this or that?"
Alex and Michael, uh, the East
Side Effects guys,
Lucian Johnston:
they have a collaboration with
Joel and they've been,
Lucian Johnston:
I think this is like their
third or fourth movie with him.
Lucian Johnston:
On this movie, we started
turning stuff over to them almost immediately.
And that really, really helped
us because there are so many
sequences in the film
Lucian Johnston:
where it's, kind of, a
conversation with the VFX department.
Lucian Johnston:
We couldn't finish cuts of
scenes until the VFX were, kind of, at a certain place.
Lucian Johnston:
And so the VFX had to, kind of,
inform the edit of certain scenes.
Lucian Johnston:
So, we had to, kind of, go
back-and-forth with them a lot, and they really made that easy.
Ahh! (Grunt)
You remember in the
apparition room, with the three
witches are talking to him?
The cauldron is, obviously we
didn't have water on set.
So the cauldron is totally
visual effect.
Alex Lemke:
Working together with the DP,
Bruno Delbonnel, was a great experience.
Alex Lemke:
For me, this time was the first
one where he was actually able
Alex Lemke:
to work completely in a sound
stage.
Alex Lemke:
Which he's known for, because he
likes to control the lighting
Alex Lemke:
to the nth degree.
So, here, he could really shine
and show us what he's capable
of.
Bruno Delbonnel:
We tried to do as much in camera
as we could.
Bruno Delbonnel:
It was not like bringing
multiple cameras and like 3D thing.
Bruno Delbonnel:
It was just like, no, one camera
then we sort it out
later in post.
And, I think there ended up
being over like 400 VFX shots.
Lucian Johnston:
Which, for a film of this size,
is a lot.
Some are very complex.
The end, the crows and
everything, is all visual
effects.
They did an amazing job.
(Cawing)
♪♪
The opportunity to work with
Joel and Frances on this
project, in particular,
Denzel Washington:
was one I couldn't miss.
To follow Joel and to see how he
works and
the level of concentration and
preparation was a sight to see.
So, it was one of the best
experiences I've had.
Stefan Dechant:
As an auteur, Joel surrounded
himself with these other artists
Stefan Dechant:
that wanted nothing more but to
participate in his creation of this world.
And I think that as an audience
member, I hope that you see
that.
I'm really proud of it.
I think it's enormously, uh,
beautiful.
I feel like I've done my job
well.
It was very special.
The time to worry about flying
is when you're on the ground.
If you don't trust the pilot,
don't go.
Denzel Washington:
We were flown around by the
most brilliant pilot
Denzel Washington:
in the business, Joel Coen.
And a brilliant co-pilot,
Frances McDormand.
So, I knew I was in good hands
and I felt free to try anything.
♪♪